good morning Hank it's Tuesday since I
forgot to ask the nerdfighters for
questions I can't do question Tuesday so
instead I'm gonna do an old-school parts
video today's video comes to you in
three parts part 1 an important
breakthrough in the field of in your
pants so Hank by now it's well known
that if you add the words in your pants
to the end of a book title that title
often becomes funnier and every so often
a nerdfighter discovers an impossibly
funny example of the in your pants rule
of course you will no doubt remember the
last one the Winnie the Pooh easy reader
Pooh gets stuck in your pants but I
think a nerdfighter named Aman might
have found an even better example of the
in your pants rule okay hey I don't want
to raise your expectations too high but
first off this book was written by
Victoria Beckham you know Victoria
Beckham she was in that girl group and
they were about to tell us what they
really really wanted and I was like yes
tell me what you really really want and
they were like do you really really want
to know what I really really want and I
was like yes I just told you and then it
turned out that instead of actually
wanting something they just wanted to
zigg a zigg
which is not even a thing so anyway
Victoria Beckham wrote a book and it is
called that extra half an inch in your
pants with the subtitle hair heels and
everything in between well Hank I don't
think you need to be an expert in
anatomy to know that a lot of what
occurs between your hair and your heels
is in fact in your pants part two
appearances Hank in the next week I'll
be making two appearances you know what
appearances are they're like this
actually it's nothing like that what
actually happens is that instead of
being a rectangle inside your computer I
become a full-fledged person arguably
too much full not enough fledged
chicago-area nerdfighters I will be in
LaGrange on October 13th more info in
the thingy
and if you're over 21 and live in or
near Indianapolis you should come hang
out with me at this awesome fundraiser
on Saturday night
check out the thingy hey nerdfighters
now that the sidebar isn't a sidebar
what should I call it oh and also if you
live in the Bay Area you have to go hang
out with the bay area nerdfighters this
Saturday October 10th check out the I
haven't named it yet
part three beckoning lovely hey there
lovely it's me John Green why don't you
come downstairs if you come down I'll
give you a pirate puppy and backslash
creeper no Hank beckoning lovely is not
about perverts and basements it's a
profoundly moving community-based
project my friend Amy Krauss Rosenthal
is doing with lots of people in
lots of nerdfighters it's pretty nerd
fight astok link as always in the
as-yet-unnamed box to which I am
diagonally connected by the way off
topic but the as-yet-unnamed box to
which I am diagonally connected would be
a good name for a band
Hank I'll see you singing tomorrow
nerdfighters thanks for being so awesome
I hope to see lots of you in Chicago and
Indianapolis it's going to be tons of
fun there will be presents and lots of
hilarity
hey there lovely you want a pirate buff
[Music]
I'm not good at being a creeper